[Musica]
qualche anno fa lavoravo in una grande e
famosa università di ricerca e nel mio
dipartimento come in tutti i
dipartimenti c'erano responsabile della
sicurezza che aveva il compito di
testare una volta al mese il sistema di
allarme che faceva un grandissimo rumore
un giorno come forse avrete intuito
c'era un incendio vero allora
responsabile la sicurezza girava per
tutti gli uffici a partire dall'ultimo
piano per essere sicuro che nessuno
rimanesse dentro apre una porta e c'era
un collega con le mani sulle orecchie
lasciami lavorare lasci lavorare ecco
questo collega forse va preso il sacro
fuoco per la scienza un po troppo
letteralmente però forse forse gli
scienziati sono proprio le persone a cui
più si prescrive questa frase famosa di
primo levi di quest'anno ricorrono i 100
anni della nascita per cui la male il
proprio lavoro costituisce
l'approssimazione più concreta alla
felicità sulla terra gli scienziati come
abbiamo sentito anche oggi molto
intensamente hanno spesso una vera e
propria vocazione per il proprio lavoro
un lavoro che a volte oscuro
un lavoro che non necessariamente va sui
giornali o da grandi gratificazioni e
anche quando queste avvengono vengono
considerate spesso come una cosa normale
che succede e poi passa sempre in quella
grande università
il giorno che christopher pista ieri
vinse il premio nobel per l'economia era
lì a mense insieme a noi in fila e
nessuno lo ha fatto neanche passare
avanti un altro italiano 500 anni fa
iniziava a riflettere qualcosa di più di
cinquecento anni fa perché quest'anno
sono i 500 anni della sua nascita
iniziava a riflettere sul metodo
scientifico ed è forse di qualcosa di
molto italiano questo è un genio
particolare che univa doti da inventore
doti di grande artista
anche iniziava a riflettere su cosa
significasse la scienza e quindi lui
diceva con questa frase famosa che si
può considerare una scienza umana solo
quella che può essere dimostrata
matematicamente ecco oggi questa è una
frase che può essere dibattuta
aspramente in dipartimenti di scienze
sociali e io stesso
tendo a non essere d'accordo con questa
frase ma come si fa a dire non sei
d'accordo con leonardo e questa però è
una delle grandi lezioni che la scienza
ci dà ogni giorno perché non si è
d'accordo o non d'accordo con una
persona ma con un concetto con un'idea è
proprio la possibilità di non essere
d'accordo e quello che ci fa andare
avanti allora forse qualcuno al posto
mio
adesso direbbe che la scienza e made in
italy perché 500 anni fa leonardo
pensava questa frase
ed è una frase che però io non dirò
perché se proprio dovessimo trovare un
luogo
allora forse dovremmo andare a sentire
quello che ci diceva il grande filosofo
tedesco che vedeva l'europa come un
leone affamato come un continente sempre
teso ad andare avanti
e in effetti l'europa ha cambiato il
mondo tante volte e volte male e quando
ha cambiato in bene è stato spesso
spesso grazie alla scienza
e allora è vero che il made in italy e
scienza così come il made in france in
media del kingdom il made in germany
eccetera eccetera però se ripensiamo
allora a cosa successe cento anni dopo
leonardo abbiamo l'inizio della scienza
moderna con newton e galilei che
naturalmente era italiano allora siccome
io noi stiamo costruendo un nuovo centro
di ricerca in italia mi piace pensare a
questo carattere e senza citare
centinaia e migliaia di scienziati che
lavorano e che hanno lavorato mi piace
citarne soltanto due ricordarne due per
ricordarli tutti insieme a rita levi
montalcini e fabiola gianotti
famosissime scienziati che con i loro
studi
come tutti gli scienziati cambiano la
vita
tutti noi ogni giorno allora io per
lavoro ho avuto la fortuna di girare
molto il mondo degli ultimi anni e gli
italiani sono sempre riconosciuti come
scienziati attenti curiosi io cercavo
in questi incontri di capire se ci fosse
qualcosa di tipico qualche qualche
ingrediente segreto e me lo disse il
capo americano di una grandissima
multinazionale una delle aziende più
grande del mondo che aveva appena aperto
in italia un nuovo stabilimento per
produrre l'ultimo suo ritrovato l'ultimo
prodotto da distribuire sul mercato e io
ero curioso di chiesto ma perché tra gli
decine di paesi in cui voi siete avete
scelto di aprire questo stabilimento
proprio in italia non in un altro paese
e le risposte perché vedi questo è un
nuovo prodotto e la sua produzione
genererà problemi inaspettati e tra
tutti gli operai gli italiani sono
quelli che hanno la caratteristica di
saper risolvere problemi inaspettati
ecco allora fondare un nuovo centro di
ricerca in italia e forse una delle cose
più tradizionali e tipiche che uno possa
fare in questo paese con un'altra però
lezione che ci viene proprio da queste
due scienziate o dai tantissimi altri
scienziati perché ricordiamoci che ci
sono pochi nomi noti ma centinaia di
migliaia di scienziati che fanno
esattamente lo stesso lavoro e non è
meno importante perché ognuno di noi può
vedere lontano perché sta sulle spalle
dei giganti che ci hanno preceduto un
bambino oggi ha più nozioni scientifiche
di leonardo perché su quelle alte spalle
allora quello che conta non è tanto il
luogo in cui si sta ma la circolarità
che si contribuisce a generare il numero
di idee che series contribuiscono a far
andare e tornare e quindi non l'antola
nazionalità ma dove si sta perché gli
scienziati alla fine vanno dove li porta
il cuore delle loro ricerche dove hanno
i loro interessi e quindi con queste due
sfide quello di compiere un passo
tradizionale di una cosa che in italia
si fa per 500 anni ovvero la sfida della
scienza più modelli
e quella di homan e la seconda sfida di
aumentare la circolarità di scambio di
idee di scienziati e di persone che
stiamo costruendo human tecnopolo a
milano adesso siamo pochi siamo una
ventina ma stiamo crescendo e cresceremo
cresceremo molto e ci siamo posti è il
nostro della nostra missione è forse la
originaria missione che è venuta in
mente al primo essere umano che ha
potuto formulare un pensiero curioso
come fare a proteggere la nostra vita
come fare a migliorare la nostra vita e
mi hanno spiegato perché io mi occupo
della governance di questo fondo di
questo centro che stiamo fondando che la
salute e l'invecchiamento degli esseri
umani dipendono da fattori intrinseci da
la genomica e da fattori estrinseci dal
nostro stile di vita cosa mangiamo come
ci comportiamo
ma la combinazione di queste due aspetti
varia da persona a persona
e allora la sfida è quella di arrivare
per questa ragione a cure sempre più
personalizzate ea prevenzioni sempre più
personalizzate per le quali sono
necessarie un insieme di discipline
molto diverse tra loro genomiche clinica
di base dell'ostica avanzata
neuroscienze
vedo già molecolare biologia strutturale
ingegneria per l'analisi di grandi masse
di dati per l'elaborazione di nuovi
algoritmi di intelligenza artificiale
necessari a processare le enormi
quantità di dati che verranno generate
dai sequenziamento del genoma e quindi
questo è il progetto cui stiamo
lavorando che quando sarà completo tra
quattro cinque sei anni al massimo e
comprenderà oltre 1200 scienziati 30mila
metri quadrati grandi infrastrutture
scientifiche di ultimissima generazione
con l'obiettivo il desiderio e la
missione chiara di raggiungere quattro
principali obiettivi il primo
naturalmente quello scientifico e quello
di avere una struttura che sia un hub un
alveare un luogo dove si entra e si esce
c'è un continuo scambio con l'esterno
per fare un esempio noi avremo delle
tecnologie
di altissima di ultimissima generazione
che avranno usata in parte dai nostri
scienziati di human tecnopolo e in parte
dagli scienziati del resto della ricerca
italiana e che potranno accedervi e non
soltanto naturalmente italiana secondo
un hub che servirà a migliorare la
qualità delle cure del sistema sanitario
nazionale
innanzi tutto italiano ma anche con le
ricerche che verranno fatte su come
questo tipo di cure possono influenzare
la sostenibilità nel tempo del sistema
sanitario anche contribuire alla
sostenibilità dei sistemi sanitari
pubblici che sono forse uno dei cuori
più importanti della civiltà del nostro
continente
terzo essere in grado di dialogare
costantemente con l'industria e la parte
economica che si occupa di scienze della
vita delle grandi settori industriali
dalla farmacia al baio tech perché
sappiamo che senza l'industrializzazione
l'industria privata riesce a generare le
scoperte non potranno arrivare nelle
case di tutte le persone che ne hanno
bisogno
quarto è infine questa è un'immagine di
palazzo italia la sera mentre stiamo
lavorando perché un paio di questi piani
già funzionano ed esistono human techno
paul vuole essere anche un ulteriore
ponte di rafforzamento tra la scienza e
la democrazia perché non dobbiamo mai
dimenticare che scienza e democrazia non
sono la stessa cosa ma sono due fratelli
gemelli hanno lo stesso dna
pensate a quante nozioni scientifiche e
voi sapete non perché le conoscete
direttamente ma perchè vi vi fidate di
chi ha fatto i conti di chi ve l'ha
raccontato sappiamo che la terra gira
attorno al sole perché non perché
l'abbiamo visto perché ci fidiamo di chi
ce l'ha spiegato e ci fidiamo di chi ce
l'ha spiegato perché si diventa
scienziati con un processo trasparente
un processo aperto non c'è un dittatore
che decide chi fa lo scienziato e per
questa e questo è quello che vogliamo
fare a human techno pop costruire una
grande autorevolezza aperta in cui la
scienza è utile per gli scienziati e
perino scienziati per gli esperti in una
materia scientifica e per gli esperti in
un mestiere o in qualcos'altro
perché non importa quanto studiamo
quanto tempo passiamo a studiare ognuno
di noi può essere esperto soltanto di un
piccolo spicchio di sapere
ed è per questo che abbiamo bisogno gli
uni degli altri e forse niente come la
scienza è una grande grande opera
collettiva un grande sforzo collettivo
di persone appassionati del nostro e
proprio lavoro e il lavoro degli
scienziati è il lavoro che stiamo
facendo noi in questo momento è in fondo
la stessa cosa un lavoro molto semplice
un lavoro uguale a quello che fanno
tante altre persone certo un po speciale
un po privilegiato io mi sento molto
fortunato di lavorare a un progetto che
costruisce un pezzetto un pezzetto di
futuro un po come quel pellegrino che
camminando incontrò 3 la persona che
spaccavano grandi pietre al sole
d'estate
la prima ha lanciato un grido di fatica
la seconda si lamentò al pellegrino
lavoro tutta la giornata per mantenere
la mia famiglia il terzo si voltò dei
sorrisi di sé sono contento perché sto
costruendo la mia cattedrale
ecco noi non stiamo in un deserto
costruire una cattedra è contrario siamo
in un posto molto denso la lombardia uno
spicchio d'europa denso di ricerca di
grandi industrie di grandi università di
grande storia ed è il motivo per il
quale in questo contorno e poi in
lombardia siamo anche qui siamo convinti
di poter siamo ottimisti di poterci
riuscire
è un'impresa sicuramente molto intensa
molto faticosa ma che ci rende molto
felice
grazie tante
[Applauso]
[Musica]